maybe just bringing some breaking news
coming into us from the states uh Donald
Trump has said he declined to answer any
questions when testifying under oath
today as part of an investigation by the
New York attorney general into his
family's business practices this of
course comes with the FBI and the
Department of Justice facing growing
calls to explain the raid on the former
president's home in Florida yesterday
well let's get the latest now from
Washington uh from our correspondent
David Blevins so David Donald Trump
agreed to take part in this
investigation he went but he apparently
didn't answer any questions according to
what he said afterwards
that's right what a week this is turning
into for the former president and it's a
change in position it would seem because
two of his children Ivana and Donald Jr
were also subpoenaed to give evidence in
relation to this investigation into
business dealings and did answer
questions but it appears the president
himself pleaded the Fifth Amendment to
avoid any possibility of incrimination
he has issued a statement in the last
few minutes saying he did so because the
attorney general for New York had
campaigned against him he describes
Leticia James as a failed politician who
described him as an illegitimate
president and therefore he said he
doesn't believe this to be a neutral
investigation that her position is
biased and of course that is a
continuation of the conspiracy claims
that he's been peddling since the FBI
raided his Mar-A-Lago home in relation
to a completely different investigation
on Monday evening he's suggesting
repeatedly that the Democrats are out to
get him because they fear he's about to
announce a run for the presidency again
in 2024 now the attorney the the
attorney general for New York was
questioning him in relation to
allegations that his company increased
the value of Assets in order to secure
uh loans and insurance policies Etc and
then reduce the value of those assets
again to avoid tax liability so that's
what he was due to answer questions on
he confirmed last night that he would
meet with the attorney general for New
York but described it as the
continuation of the greatest Witch Hunt
in U.S history saying myself and my
company are being attacked from all
sides labeling America a Banana Republic
so he has gone today to respond to the
subpoena but it appears now he has
chosen not to answer any questions and
perhaps we'll get more detail about his
decision to do that as the day continues